are there some practical
games of Power that occurred
you know in the way that Stalin took
power and held power in the early days
was there something like this in terms
of the establishment of the
Revolutionary guard and all those kinds
of stuff yes so it's the the Messianic
figure that has some support from the
people but uh does he have to crush his
enemies in competition
it certainly did
probably not certainly not as brutal in
terms of the victims as you would see in
Soviet Union understanding
who the Bloodshed were the
destruction of the population was far
greater
than what you would find in
Iran of the Islamic Republic it's
uncomfortable
perhaps I would find a greater parallel
with Martin
[Music]
and
particularly because China has a very
strong Messianic tradition
since the ancient times so they have
something and Mao appeared as the kind
of a Messianic figure
there I can see there is a parallel but
also you can see with any other
authoritarian regime with the Messianic
fear at the head of it that it destroys
all the other forces so during course of
the first 10 years of the Islamic
revolution it destroyed the liberal
nationalists
secular
it's destroyed
the Guerrilla movements some of them
Islamic some of them marxists who turned
into political parties or tendencies in
the course of the post-revolution 1979
they were completely destroyed
and in a very brutal fashion
and uh the their opposition even within
the religious establishment because it
wasn't a uniform there were many
different Tendencies those that were
opposed to the authority of Ayatollah
Khomeini or not Imam Khomeini meaning
almost the sacred
religious figure above the level of a
religious Authority is a saint kind of a
figure he says she's has this idea of
imams they were 11 of them the 12th is
hidden and would come back at the end of
the time Messianic figure
so the title that was always used for
them only in shiza never used for any
other person
he is the first person in the revolution
of 1979 first referred to as Deputy of
Imam
but the term Deputy gradually
disappeared and he became Imam Khomeini
this is that's his official title I love
human beings so much
it's so beautiful these uh titles that
we give each other it's um but it's
marvelous too you love it because you
haven't been under that system no I I
love it in a way I love it in a very
dark dark
kind of way it caricatures itself it's
it's almost
or funny in this absurdity if not for
the evil that it has led to in human
history uh but also the fact that it's a
man is in fact fulfillment in a kind of
completely
um unintended fashion it's a fulfillment
of that idea of a messiah that they've
been fighting for this Imam which is in
ahide for a thousand years is here and
not here
and therefore Khomeini would have in
effect fulfilled those anticipations but
beyond that I just give you one example
I know that you may have other concerns
but
when I say elimination
at the end of the iran-iraq war
by the direct order of Ayatollah
Khomeini a fatwa that he wrote a group
of prisoners
who belong to a variety of uh
political parties the left religious
left
majority of them
the left and the the Marxist left and
the religious left
um in a matter of a few weeks or perhaps
a few months I'm not actually quite sure
about the times that
in a series of these were people who
have already been tried
and they were given uh sentences
they've approached back
before the uh summary Trials of three
judges or more three four of them one of
them is now the
new president of the Islamic Republic I
see
and they were given a a quick summary
sentences which meant uh execution
so something between probably six to
eight thousand
were executed in a matter of a month or
two months something like that
mostly into Iran but also in provinces
um and that remained an extraordinary
trauma
for the families for those who had these
kids in they're all young all young
so this remains very much a
kind of uh original sin of the Islamic
Republic
that cannot get rid of
and it's in people's memories they
didn't allow them even the families
to go and mourn
their dead in a an official symmetry
which they created for them now the
latest thing is that they put a huge a
concrete wall around it so nobody would
be able to get into it so these all part
of this extraordinary level of
level of
atrocity
brutality that you see that the regime
claimed that it comes with the morality
of religion and Islam to bring back the
justice and and and be more
uh in a sense kind to people ended up
with what it is in the memory of many of
the people in Iraq so developing these
fascistic Tendencies very much
destroying minorities Baha'i is one of
them
hundreds of bahais were without any
reason without any involvement we picked
up and uh
executed the properties were taken over
their rights were taken away from them
even up to this day this is the largest
by the very religious minority in Iran
so you would see that in many areas
this is a ax very much as an Beyond
authoritarian it's a kind of really a
fascistic regime